welcome back now a 21 year old man has
been arrested on suspicion of trespass
after he was seen climbing the shard
building in central london police
officers were called to the skyscraper
at around half past five this morning a
number of cordons were put in place
while emergency services responded to
the incident two other men were arrested
on suspicion of causing public nuisance
well we can speak now paul curfey who
was staying on the 40th floor of the
shard and saw the man waving as he
climbed past their window good to see
you paul so you were staying in the
hotel at the top of the shard uh tell me
what happened this morning
um we've basically heard some shouting
about four o'clock in the about six of
the morning
and so we looked out the window to see
adam basically walked up past our window
and he stopped he waved um we were
celebrating my partner's 40th birthday
so it's a bit of a shock but at the same
time
he seemed happy seemed confident and
the message we saw was basically speak
out save lives which was on his t-shirt
so
um obviously
i don't should do what he's actually
done i don't condone anyone walking for
building but at the same time
sometimes a message has to be out there
somehow
so you were asleep and he knocked on the
window and you open the cage
with the curtains i'm not
that far our curtains are open um my
partner was half naked but at the same
time
um we just literally heard some voices
from downstairs so i think there's
police there's five brigade that's also
to the bottom of the actual building
um
which workers because we always wake up
early anyway and then we saw adam walk
past the window he stopped and he seemed
quite happy seemed really confident and
waved at us and then carried on up the
building so
it was a bit of a strange strange
weekend
you've all got sort of visions going
through our minds at the moment uh paul
so you were sorry
you encouraged him to keep going
no i didn't encourage him at all but um
if somebody got to the 40th floor then
um there's not far to go to the top so
um i wouldn't condone anyone finding a
building but um he seemed confident he
seemed happy seemed relaxed and
i don't really want to say it was just
the experience that i won't forget ever
so
yeah and i think i read somewhere that
your partner thought you might have
arranged this for her birthday and
yeah well i've done all the stop stop
strategies in the shards so i did the
balloons and the pedals and all sorts
things are batted up in the window
luckily she wasn't in the bathtub at the
time so um
i think um she thought i'd actually send
the cabbage milk tray guy up the actual
to climb the actual shards knock on the
window and give him a milk tray but um
maybe that didn't happen so
you thought it was the middle if you'd
like heavy duty if he had that if she
hadn't if you had a box of milk tray
then i think she'd quite impressed with
for your birthday that's pretty um
that's pretty out there
yeah fantastic and we were you scared
for him i don't know about you but i am
no no until he looked and will actually
look really confident
and to do something like that you have
to be in the right frame of mind and you
have to be
confident to be able to do that you
wouldn't even think of doing that if you
weren't in the right frame of mind so
yeah and uh uh it was a birthday treat
did you enjoy the rest of your day
without any interaction um yeah we're
celebrating tonight um it's a birthday
tonight so we'll be um yeah celebrating
for the rest of night so it was
definitely a different weekend
yeah and i know you don't condone this
sort of stuff but scaling a thousand
foot building barefooted is pretty
impressive isn't it
i've denied my triathlons before um hats
off i i'm scared of heights anyway so
even looking at the actual window was
bad enough so to do what he's doing um i
couldn't even think of even getting into
the first floor so
um yeah
you and me both uh well
what a weekend and you've got a great uh
story to tell paul curfew thank you very
much indeed telling us what happened